the mozzarella family has been growing
fruits and vegetables in the state of
new jersey for four generations it's
always been an unpredictable business
but this year profit margins are
exceptionally tight and workers hard to
come by it used to be
three four years ago there was people
coming in and out of the yard all year
long looking for jobs this year i don't
think one car pulled in the yard to look
for work from fuel to fertilizer
according to the government production
expenses in the farm sector are
projected to increase more than 5
percent this year the cost of fertilizer
has more than doubled this season that's
largely due to the war in ukraine which
combined with the coronavirus pandemic
has led to a host of supply chain issues
driving up costs for farmers
labor costs the biggest expense for
fruit and vegetable farmers have also
gone up
many here in new jersey are paying top
dollar to import pickers under a special
visa program but they're competing
against countries that pay much less and
grow year round
so far this year the amount of imported
fruits and vegetables in the u.s has
surged 13 percent according to the
department of agriculture putting many
east coast farms at risk
because grocery stores these days want a
year-round consistent supply and we are
a seasonal production area we can't
supply everything 12 months of the year
so people are going to have to think a
little bit differently about how they
deal in the wholesale market
it's going to be a challenge
some farmers are selling directly to
local consumers attempting to diversify
their crops and their customer base and
in may president biden authorized
funding to produce more fertilizer
domestically as well as incentives for
u.s farmers to plant more crops to help
make up for shortfalls of ukrainian
wheat but it may be too late for tom
shepard who's looking to downsize his
operation and expenses he currently
employs more than 200 people
unless the american consumer
requests the supermarkets to stock local
you know at least the u.s made stuff
we're going to have a tough time because
we our wages are so much higher farmers
think it's a small price to pay to
preserve local jobs and farmland kristin
salumi al jazeera cedarville new jersey